[Music]
[Music]
we're really at the beginning stages but
we we certainly view overwatch league as
a huge business opportunity on its own
it's not something we're doing just to
get people to play overwatch or just to
sell more copies that watch we really
think it's a significant business
opportunity to monetize the sport of
overwatch in the same way that
traditional sports pot sizes which is
let's have matches let's build an
audience around the content and then
monetize the audience through meteorites
and sponsorship and tickets and
merchandise and all of those avenues for
Blizzard to realize its vision of
overwatch League as the future of
eSports entertainment it aspired to
operate on a much larger scale than
other competitive scenes had so far to
do this and to do it right out of the
gate it needed partners to make hefty
investments in its grand plans
well-known eSports outfits such as cloud
9 optic gaming and energy were ideal
candidates having already established
eSports teams in other games and seen
the inherent value in eSports
[Music]
but Blizzard also reached beyond video
games and into traditional sports
business and culture attracting
recognizable names such as
telecommunications giant Comcast and the
Kraft Group owner of the New England
Patriots not to mention more unexpected
backers such as basketball legend
Shaquille O'Neal and pop diva Jennifer
Lopez while these celebrity figures are
largely divorced from the day-to-day
operations of overwatch League their
willingness to put money behind the bold
ideas at such an early stage speaks to
the potential impact they could have on
the landscape of eSports San Francisco
San Jose oak town Sacramento look at
this team baby we're gonna do so great
here we come baby energy in this episode
we sat down with the people most
committed to blizzards vision for the
growth of eSports the people who
invested time and a whole lot of money
to chart the future of the overwatch
league
[Music]
I think that you know celebrities
investing high-profile people investing
in overwatch and in eSports is is a
broader statement about the state of
eSports right now that everybody is
either a gamer or has a gamer very close
in their life right and that's that's
like a pretty foundational shift that's
happening culturally in at least America
you know that's that's how you know that
eSports and video games are hitting
mainstream adoption when you have those
types of influential people putting bets
and putting their own money into it well
I think people see the power of
overwatch as a game you know it's over
thirty five million players incredibly
global I think one things that's super
interesting about overwatch you know
there are a lot of games that are really
big in the US are really big in China
overwatch is very broadly distributed we
have a big player in the u.s. being
player of us and you're up big player
rates in China Korea Australia South
East Asia Middle East so overwatch is
truly global I mean we have players
everywhere so I think that's really
compelling so I think when when the
investors you mentioned are coming and
looking at it that's something that's
super compelling also again like the art
style like how appealing it is to such a
broad audience you know the core of our
audience is 13 and 34 year olds I don't
know how much you follow the
demographics of traditional sports it's
not 13 to 30 for the average age of a
major league baseball fan of North
America is like 56 next year it will be
57 that'll be 58 then it'll be 59 the
young people that are engaging with this
content it's not like when they turn 40
they're gonna magically become baseball
fans
Blizzard's pitch was based on the idea
that what modern audiences look to for
entertainment is on the cusp of a
cultural shift an overwatch league would
be positioned to capitalize on an
increased interest in eSports more
importantly unlike other eSports teams
and tournaments there would be inbuilt
permanence so an investment in overwatch
league would effectively be an
investment in the growth of eSports
admittedly it's a big leap for anyone to
take but for investors having Activision
Blizzard leading the charge alleviated
fears Robert and Jonathan craft I would
like to think they're they're always
looking for innovation they're always
looking for the next big
and I think they see that no matter what
with eSports that is the future and they
want to be a part of that and they want
to bring what they have in traditional
sports and what has helped them exceed
and be excellent in that space to
eSports so I think when they looked at
Blizzard Activision and they looked at
that partnership and they looked at the
people that would be running it they had
confidence that this would be something
that is gonna succeed long term Blizzard
being involved is paramount I think you
know everybody loves Blizzard games they
have an incredible track record they
understand great design great character
building you know many like and Blizzard
to like the Pixar of games right so I
think having Blizzard be the champion of
this makes us feel much more comfortable
as investors and you know for me got me
pretty excited so I think it made a lot
of sense the things that they were
attempting to do
I had already was hoping to see that
happen maybe over the next 5 years to a
decade they pushed it way forward so
that you know goals I didn't expect to
see for a while we're gonna be happening
a next year Jack are you in or you're
out I'm like oh my god I'm here like
this is fantastic when I saw how
seriously they were taking the overwatch
league I knew I had to be a part of it I
immediately just spoke to the folks that
invest in cloud 9 and people are
thinking about being a part of cloud 9
like this is something that it's
mission-critical for us or there's never
a chance where I didn't think I was
going to do it
it's not often that a whole new sport is
invented and for those that currently
exist it's rare for new teams to emerge
within them in most cases
there are very few new entry points into
the business of traditional sports
[Music]
esports however still has plenty of
doors open it has always been targeted
at hardcore and is only now beginning to
step out in front of a broader
mainstream audience for investors this
is effectively the chance to get in on
the ground level of what could
potentially be one of these sports for
the gaming generation I think a lot of
the pro sports community and especially
the business around pro sports has an
awareness of an aging fanbase and
they're trying to attract new fans into
those sports but it's challenging you
know you can't force people to be into
something they're either into it or
they're not one thing that I think is
exciting about overwatch League is not
only is the game very approachable and
feels like it has these warm welcoming
open arms to to everybody but there's a
really thriving young passionate
community that's been growing around the
game and I think people see that and go
wow not only is this cool and they want
to be a part of that but there's also a
tremendous business opportunity there
that we've captured an audience that
other more traditional sports are having
a difficult time getting their attention
you watch what you grew up with those
habits are gonna are gonna stick with
people and so I think a lot of our team
owners that were coming from the
traditional sports world see that shift
and they see how kids are engaging with
gaming and it's not just playing games
anymore it's playing games and then also
watching long-form video game content
it's not short two-minute videos it's
watching for hours that that sort of
change in the way that people consume
and the type of content that people
consume that it's not gonna magically
change when when they when they get out
of the 13 to 30 for whole demographic
they're gonna that's gonna they gonna
continue on in much the same way that
like my generation of dads plus or minus
a few years is the first generation of
dads that's never not played video games
I do not remember a single moment of
my life where I did not have video games
in it that's why I'm pretty confident
that in the future from I wouldn't put
labels on Millennials they don't they
have enough already
but you know eSports fans will start to
become much more mainstream because more
people are playing them and getting
accustomed to them and it's a way to
connect across very large distances and
with family members you know you I think
I like the analogy of playing baseball
the catch you know with your father
teaching son how to catch right like
okay I'm not gonna do that with my son
but you know we love to play video games
together whether you know whether it's
overwatch or some other game I think
that'll be a great way to connect with
my you know kids and then when they go
off to college or whatever we can still
connect and then you know if we want to
go to a sporting event what is it
probably gonna be maybe we want to see
the pros play so I I can in my mind see
that future playing out very easily the
twenty million dollar buy-in to
overwatch League includes ownership of a
team franchise which would be tied to a
particular region with this bias could
hit multiple key demographics and give
them a compelling reason to get involved
with the league for the hardcore the
teams and players would be lightning
rods for their love of the game or
eSports generally for everyone else
aligning a team where the city could
ignite the local pride that fuels the
most passionate rivalries in traditional
sports one of the core things that I'm a
huge believer in is the regional base
teams and a lot of people were
questioning this decision at first when
we announced it because it was very
foreign to eSports but for so many of us
you grew up as sports fans you realize
that there was this local loyalty to the
hometown team and we wanted people to
experience that to know what it's like
it's perfectly fine not to cheer for
your hometown team but if you if you
don't know any better and want the
decision to be made for you you could
pick who's kind of local to me so that
will make it really easy for people to
get into it and immediately feel a bond
and feel a sense of belonging like
they're included in the
the other thing is we looked at the team
model in eSports and there's so many
teams the the barrier to starting a team
is very low and there wasn't a lot of
revenue opportunities for teams so you
had a lot of people coming in and
creating teams and I think some of the
problems that mission earlier around
players was because people would start
teams they maybe bite off more than they
could chew and there wasn't a lot of
revenue there so we had to think about
like how do we how do we make this
sustainable for teams so they were
talking about a league that would always
have that visibility and that was was
like for me that was wow that's
something else and then out on top of
that they're they're gonna be focusing a
little flow localization so hey I need
to go pick up a city ok well it's
something I've never done before it was
scary
ladies and gentlemen introducing the
London Spitfire but it's come with a
whole learning curve of things I've had
to pick up but I could see the
tremendous value in it it also really
sparked the excitement of traditional
sports teams whoo that's a business
model that are very familiar with so it
brought people to the eSports table that
really hadn't gotten involved before
better really important to the business
of bringing in sponsors and supporters
the league that was pretty
groundbreaking stuff that's very excited
about it we're talking about investors
like the ones that we have from
professional sports the ones we have
from eSports who are looking at I want
to be I'm gonna build something I'm
gonna build a brand but a build a legacy
around this team I want to win
championships and and having not having
to worry about making a certain record
each year to remain in the league allows
teams the freedom to hey it may be I
actually think that this 18 year old is
gonna be the best player in the league
in two years so I'm gonna build my team
around him today and they have the
ability to take risk like that to invest
in infrastructure and the players to
invest in young players we think that's
very important for building a league
from scratch so we want to create you
know consistency and stability for team
owners that actually could be
sustainable on terms of business and
then from a fan perspective also give
fans this the the sort of
stability of hey like I'm gonna be a fan
of this team and I don't have to worry
about this team going away so by having
the city based teams we thought there's
sort of two things that we can do there
one is what we know it works in
traditional sports for all the reasons
it works like I'm from the city year my
wife's from the city here oh it's
College in the city like you have the
connection and it gives you a reason to
care immediately I know I know what New
York is I can decide to root for that or
not I have some context there the other
thing is it gives us back to that point
around the teams it gives us a path to
sustainability from business perspective
we can host events there eventually and
people who live in New York I can go be
a fan and go experience Washington New
York with other people from New York
it's the same reason that it's way more
fun to go like when I was the first time
everyone some really a Premier League
game and I went to White Hart Lane and I
saw Tottenham play that was way better
than ever watching it on television
because you got the experience you're
sitting with 40,000 other people you're
singing songs you're having this shared
connection over your passion for the
sport I think that's important to
represent your city to invest in your
market to make sure that we do
everything for the growth of
Philadelphia born
overwatch players and Philadelphia
region eSports fans in general we've
already shown some cool fusion
highlights in the Wells Fargo Center in
the middle of the fires near an
intermission right like I'm a huge
Flyers fan or a huge fusion fan and so
there's there we're out there and when
you hit that note they're like oh my god
yeah
but absolutely Philadelphia fans they
love their city they want to represent
their city we want to win or we want the
other guy to lose and we want to boo
them but you know perhaps the most
obvious commitment to overwatch league's
future is the blizzard arena based in
Burbank California it is served as the
battleground for the first four stages
of competitive overwatch League stepping
inside it it's hard not to get swept up
into blizzards ambition and understand
why replicating this live experience
within the cities each overwatch league
team represents is so critical not only
to generating excitement for eSports
from a broader audience but because it
creates more revenue opportunities for
investors in our view the best path to
creating value in eSports is getting
stability for Team owners through the
franchising system we have having the
city based model where teams will play
home games in those cities which will
unlock a ton of value in local markets
that don't exist today and a ton more
opportunities for fans to be able to go
and engage with the content we think
over time that's really gonna continue
to grow the value that's a really
interesting fun part for me in having a
local presence it's something completely
new to me so getting a local sponsorship
and having ticket sales and having
access to the sales of the broadcast
like this is these are all new things so
it's really fun and exciting and
different historically every sponsorship
dollar that come into cloud9
I had to do that and it was just for us
now we've got league wide sponsorships
and the league wide sponsorships that
are coming and are mind blowing in their
size and their scope so when you're
looking to build a team where revenue is
based on local sponsorships if I'm able
to capture not just like one city but
almost an entire countries like
sponsorship opportunities its massive so
when I'm out there looking to close
local sponsorships I have a very large
region with a massive population behind
it
people looking go to the games and and
businesses behind they can support it so
for me it just seemed like a no-brainer
like you're gonna get that to me I'm on
it right now I think you know there may
be some viewership fatigue and even in
markets I'm fatigued because there's so
many matches in Burbank California but
as we move to our respective regions
there's gonna be a whole nother uptick
in interest and you know what are you
doing Friday night you want to go to a
match
sure let's check it out that's how you
make really hardcore fan bases is going
to events and having a social fun
experience with it that's something that
eSports has just never had tournaments
don't do that you have chance for one
side chance for another side it's kind
of like the Olympics or like the Super
Bowl it's kind of cool but when you have
a hometown night and match like it's
it's it's a whole different atmosphere
and it's a lot of fun
[Music]
I was explaining that investors I'm like
we see 40,000 concurrence like day one
that's like the average over the over
the year this thing is just crushed it
and then we open up a 400,000 like oh
wow that's awesome and it consistently
been around 100 the metrics have had to
shift and not that that applies to every
part of the league so far how quickly we
would see in game like skins what type
of sponsorships and the value behind
them every single like milestone that I
had set before I had signed up has
already been complete a lot of the water
and vastly exceeded my expectations so I
need to retool what that'll be while
overwatch leagues backers wait to reap
the benefits of their investments the
players competing within it have already
felt the impact of dedicating their
lives to the game and the competition on
the next episode we speak to the people
at the heart of the league the players
who reveal the sacrifices they've made
for the life of a pro gamer and whether
it was worth it
[Music]